today's topic somebody sent me this on
IG Korea she thought that she wear her
baby yo with her baby doordashing you
can do it
period she thought that she were her
baby yo with her baby doordash and you
can do it so it's a woman who's
doordashing but she has her baby with
her she's got the doordash food in one
hand and a baby in the carriage and on
the other oh okay and then the person
says door dashing with her baby you can
do it no excuses but I I can't
understand how people don't find it
appropriate you know you're gonna leave
your kid in the car while you're going
through the food and everything and
stuff I get that I get how people is
going to be but I don't really
necessarily see a problem with it you
know what's your problem with it no then
illegally you're not supposed to leave
your kid in the car no she's actually
carrying the kid with one hand so this
is an interesting thing right try to do
it I'll watch this video and people like
you can do it no excuses and it made me
think of like a few things go ahead
one to me to me really the big thing for
me I think it's just it's sad that
people have to do that that's what's sad
when people say no excuses I'm like
that's definitely an excuse
you should not be doing that
I'm sorry for that no excuse excuses
yeah that's not right like listen you
got a child you can't afford daycare and
you're trying to figure out like that's
an excuse like like this is that part of
that hustle mentality where we glorify
stories like these yeah look she's
carrying her kid to the boom she's doing
the thing
no excuses if she can't do it what's
your excuse uh I'm responsible
and he's biking around yeah right yeah
he's on a scooter that's crazy so to me
it's just
that's the reality of the world we live
in things financially are so bad and
some folks don't have any ways of doing
stuff that they got to take their kids
with them to go to work
that's sad
and I know she's not doing this with the
employer's knowledge so she's having to
do this under the table and it's not
that and people are glorifying it being
like no excuses that's the [ __ ] that
makes me crazy not doing it like at a
bad attention
it's not it's not you know it's not
having bad intentions you don't want to
pay your [ __ ] bills exactly the
thing the thing what makes you the only
time that that you're able that I used
to see kids at at the job was whenever
someone left for maternity and came back
to work to show everybody their
co-workers their kids and I'm like I
would never girl you you're really proud
of what came out of your [ __ ] cause I
would never go back to work I work with
y'all yeah it's like
think about it you gotta dress up the
baby pack up the clothes put that
[ __ ] in the car uh drive your
whole ass to the other and then show it
and then the uh oh no change diapers on
the spot you if either you miss work
that much yeah oh you're really proud of
what came out of your [ __ ] to show it
or you really care about those
[ __ ] because I didn't oh best
believe they were not my friends I know
a lot of like I know a lot of women who
have kids who try to look professional
at work and they do everything they can
and they could never even imagine
bringing a kid because they would never
be taken or there's a stigma as a mom
absolutely right absolutely to have to
bring your kid to work but that shows
you what kind of financial circumstances
exist in this country for most people in
general that people are struggling at
home making ends meet trying to pay rent
try to pay their bills trying to have
any kind of disposable income daycare is
expensive as [ __ ] it is a luxury so you
best hope you got family who can help
you with the daycare or else you paying
out the white suit for it yeah so I
understand I just think the hustle
culture is what I'm not a big fan of
this whole lot no excuses I just don't
like it that's because it sends the
wrong message instead of saying instead
of the picture someone by the bootstraps
you can make it be honest like
understand the financial circumstances
of the side we live in how like
untenable it is for poor people that's
what it really is about poor people
should not have to do [ __ ] like that
to keep a job we should all agree people
got to work hard okay cool all that cool
stuff taking your kid to work
that to me is just sad you might see it
as a beautiful hard-working thing and I
can understand that angle to some degree
but if we're also being honest it's
[ __ ] sad because odds are they're
gonna find out she did this and they're
gonna make her lose her job do you guys
still think it's no excuses then when
she gets fired what's she gonna do at
the next job because I can assure you
other than delivery there's not too many
jobs you can do where you're taking care
of a baby
except if you do daycare but yeah but
that also the fact that the society you
know is made for you you can't it's
really hard to live alone in this
Society to do things to buy a house to
buy our loan it's not made like that
it's very [ __ ] up for that so yeah
it's crazy yeah taking your kid to work
especially when they're in a little baby
carriage like that doesn't strike me as
the most safe environment it's not but
you're walking
so let's say she would walk with her
with her kid to go get some food that's
basically what you're doing but she's
doing that multiple times you know it
depends on the nature of the work right
people walk their kids to their car
every day people go to get food every
day with their kids
to me it's just
copy and repeat okay so why at a lot of
jobs like these do they not allow
children to be present because they
don't allow children to be present
because it becomes it can become
something that uh what's a word
a distraction for other people right she
works alone she doordashes you know I
mean people are gonna be yelling you're
gonna be on the phone you're gonna have
toddlers Excuse Me Miss can I put you on
a hole don't do this don't do that
that's why there's distraction for other
people she works alone who gives a [ __ ]
distraction for other people social
distraction for her sure your kid is not
priority so if there's something that
happens the horse you have to leave your
kid behind somewhere you have to run
back and forth and John made me take you
to do stuff anyone who sees this and
then an accident happens what is the
first thing they're gonna say okay
they're gonna say it's a bad mom was a
bad move why
because the kid was there and she put
the kids in arms away that's I
understand what the people are going to
say but it's not because the people say
it that it's inherently bad and that
that I don't uncomfort I don't think
it's really that bad especially in that
thing I'm gonna take I gotta I'm gonna
take the context I'm gonna take the
thing in context it's gonna depend it's
gonna depend what job what job obviously
if a [ __ ] cop
I don't expect you to take your [ __ ]
kids out to work you know but bring
bring kids to to Daddy that's not a job
that I would do that I agree you know I
mean it depends hold this gun right
through it cover me Daddy Daddy the gun
too big that's not this UPS again
there's boxes and [ __ ] like that not
doordash here's my thing here's my thing
I agree with what you're saying I think
it's an issue for me I don't see this I
don't see it as that much of a risk to
be honest there's things that are more
risky than that than we allow people to
do like what
kids yeah go ahead
anything from going to the just leaving
your kids with strangers that's one
thing that I'm like that's [ __ ] up you
haven't done a background chat we don't
do background checks to [ __ ]
kindergartens and [ __ ] like that I think
that's more [ __ ] up
you don't do background check on your
kindergarten they don't necessarily
kindergartens are mandated by the state
to do backgrounds depending depending on
where you are sure but generally so so
so depending of where you are and even
with that background check you don't
know what the morals of the person is
You're Gonna Leave the education the
whole education of the earliest years of
I could go into that but I'm like meh go
I think that is actually worse than the
the of your kid at the daycare is worse
yeah it could be in some cases I don't
know the person I'm in the unknown now
if some [ __ ] happens to my kid at least
I'm with I'm with my kid I'm the one
that sees it and if some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
it's on me you gotta leave the kid in
the car when you're going in to grab the
orders or when you're going to she could
take it out with the kid what you mean
she could take the kid out she was
carrying the kid with the food wasn't
she right so she can bring her kid and
here's her doordash I'm gonna tell you
this right now if somebody sees some
person pull up to the door they're
calling the complaint so you can't you
can't do that that's not a reasonable
thing so you have to leave the no but
that's the real part of it you can't
take your kid with you with every door
because I promise you somebody gonna
have an issue with it it's possible
Right
you you don't take your kid out whenever
you put some gas in your car you get out
and you go pay you don't everybody pay
at the pump so I'm like whatever that's
a whatever to me that's whatever it is
that that's a big whatever to me but I
do understand your point I do under uh
everything that you said I agree with I
agree I agree with a lot of times I'm
not sitting here like yeah
so I'm like so I'm like yeah I get your
point to me it's also a matter of like
nobody gonna take you serious at your
job but I think preach better some good
points in regards to safety so let us
know what you guys in the comments below
we want to hear from you would you guys
be willing to do something like this and
if so tell us why if not tell us why as
well